en sport les concurrents du dakar
franchiront la ligne d'arrivée
aujourd'hui à buenos aires en moto le
français cyril depres est est en tête
dans les derniers kilomètres en cadets
gorille auto rien n'est joué julien
benedetto et régis mater on dirait
presque qu'il sort d'un footing
cyril després vient d'engloutir sur sa
moto 8500 km en deux semaines et le
français survolent ce dakar avec plus
d'une heure d'avancé sur le norvégien où
les valses et et avant dernière étape
aujourd'hui il a quasiment course gagnée
après quelques mois l'entraînement avec
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
concentration dans ses 14 derniers jours
voilà on déguste les derniers kilomètres
décor de rêve pour compétition à
couteaux tirés les pilotes s'annonce
électrique aujourd'hui dans la catégorie
autos deux pilotes de la même écurie se
disputent la victoire finale ce matin
l'espagnol carlos sainz possède deux
minutes 48 secondes d'avancé sur nasser
al attiyah
hier ça a chauffé entre les deux hommes
le qatari accuse le madrilène de l'avoir
volontairement bloqué sur la piste
dernière étape aujourd'hui longue de 200
kilomètres on attend plusieurs centaines
de milliers de personnes dans les rues
de buenos aires les argentins ne sont
pas sûrs de voir le dakar dans leur pays
l'année prochaine car les organisateurs
envisagent un retour en afrique